défense et de sécurité nationale
consacrée à l'épidémie de kovy de 19 et
un conseil des ministres qui a lui aussi
vous l'imaginez était largement
consacrée à l'épidémie dans notre pays
le constat est sans appel notre
situation épidémique se dégradent très
nettement il ya quelques jours je
parlais d'un début de vagues fulgurante
et cela se confirme avec un taux de
reproduction du virus le fameux air qui
est estimée aujourd'hui à 1,6 et qui
devrait très probablement continuer à
augmenter dans les prochains jours et
les prochaines semaines le nombre de
carats quotidien augmente de près de 80%
en une semaine et s'établit aujourd'hui
autour de 20 mille cas par jour en
moyenne hier plus de 30 mille cas
positifs ont été relevé un nombre
comparable à celui observé au plus haut
de la quatrième vague le taux
d'incidence national s'élève à 191 pour
100000 habitants et devrait dépasser les
200 d'ici demain ou après demain il est
supérieur à 100 dansant dans 93
département est déjà supérieur à 200
dans 34 départements cette vague de
contamination est une chose mais vous le
savez et je lui ai rappelé la semaine
dernière ici encore avec l'arrivée du
vaccin c'est la situation à l'hôpital
qui est et qui reste vraiment le nerf de
la guerre parce que le vaccin réduit
drastiquement le risque de formes graves
et que nous observons donc plus la même
corps et la corrélation que dans les
précédentes vagues les trois premières
entre le nombre de contaminations et le
nombre de formes graves qui nécessitent
une hospitalisation une étude
israélienne récentes confirment encore
une nouvelle fois l'efficacité de la
vaccination et du rappel le risque
d'hospitalisation et de cinquante trois
pour mille pour un non vaccinés il chute
à 9,6 pour mille pour un vacciner deux
doses et il chute à 1 8 pour mille pour
un vacciner trois doses cela confirme
une nouvelle fois l'efficacité de la
vaccination et l'efficacité du rappel à
l'hôpital le flux d'hospitalisations a
augmenté de 40% sur la dernière semaine
et l'on compte 10 à 20% de personnes
hospitalisées en plus à l'heure actuelle
la situation est encore relativement
contenue à l'hôpital et les
modélisations dons nous disposons si
elle prévoit une hausse importante de la
tension hospitalière au cours des
prochaines semaines estime que nous
pouvons éviter la submersion à condition
de poursuivre et d'amplifier nos efforts
dans la vaccination dans les gestes
barrières et dans le pass sanitaire être
au rendez vous de ces impératifs est
fondamentale si nous voulons éviter de
revivre ce que nous avons vécu lors des
trois premières vagues de l'épidémie est
ce que nos voisins traversent à nouveau
nous le voyons malheureusement tous les
jours nous avons de l'avancé nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui dans la même
situation que celle qu'ils vivent grâce
aux mesures que nous avons prises très
tôt et notamment le pass sanitaire dès
cet été grâce aux efforts qui ont été
fournis fournis par les français grâce à
leur civisme grâce à notre couverture
vaccinale mais nous ne pouvons pas nous
reposer sur cette avance l'enjeu c'est
de protéger les français face à la vague
en consolidant nos acquis et en
renforçant notre organisation de manière
à sauver les fêtes de fin d'année et a
traversé l'hiver le mieux possible c'est
sur la base de ces objectifs que le
conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale s'est réunie ce matin avec un
cap clair que je veux réitérer à nouveau
ne pas avoir en revenir à des mesures de
jauge et encore moins des mesures de
fermeture de couvre-feu ou de
confinement dans notre pays des
orientations claires ont été actés ce
matin dans trois directions d'abord le
renforcement des mesures barrières et du
port du masque en intérieur comme en
extérieur l'aération l'ensemble des
mesures barrières qui permettent de nous
protéger vis-à-vis des contaminations
ensuite le renforcement du pass
sanitaires pour mettre davantage de
contraintes sur les non vaccinés que sur
les vacciner c'est notre logique vous le
savez depuis l'allocution du président
de la république le 12 juillet dernier
enfin l'accélération de la campagne de
rappel vaccinal ses orientations et les
mesures possibles seront présentés cet
après midi aux présidents des groupes
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat et demain matin aux
associations d'élus locaux il a par
ailleurs été demandé aux différents
ministres de concerter cet après midi et
demain matin chacun leur secteur sur ses
orientations et sur les mesures que nous
serons amenés à prendre à l'issue de
cette concertation le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé tiendra
demain à la mi journée une conférence de
presse pour annoncer les mesures qui
auront été retenues à la lumière de ces
concertations et de ce travail vous le
voyez notre philosophie n'a pas changé
nous prenons des décisions sur le
fondement des recommandations sanitaires
et en concertation avec les élus nous
prenons nos décisions compte tenu de ce
que nous avons appris des vagues
précédentes de ce qui a marché et de ce
qui n'a pas marché nous prenons nos
décisions enfin en suivant le cap fixé
par le président de la république le 12
juillet dernier protégé inciter et faire
peser les contraintes sur celles et ceux
qui ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités plutôt que sur les
autres le conseil des ministres a
également été l'occasion d'examiner
plusieurs textes sur lesquels je reviens
rapidement d'abord la ministre de la
culture a présenté une ordonnance
relative qui complète la transposition
d'une directive européenne relative aux
droits d'auteur sur le marché numérique
c'est un texte qui va permettre
d'adapter notre droit pour concilier au
mieux le respect des droits d'auteur
d'un côté et la fouille des textes et de
donner ainsi que le recours à des
extraits d'oeuvres à des fins
scientifiques et d'enseignement de
l'autre ce texte c'est également la
culture pour tous puisqu'il va permettre
aux bibliothèques aux musées et aux
archives de numériser et de diffuser y
compris en ligne et par delà les
frontières de l'union dans l'union
européenne des oeuvres dont elle dispose
mais qui sont indisponibles dans le
commerce
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique a présenté une
ordonnance codifiant la partie
législative du code général de la
fonction publique cette modification va
permettre de rendre le droit de la
fonction publique plus lisible et plus
accessible pour les millions de
fonctionnaires concernés nous avons
ensuite entendu trois communications la
première du ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance portait sur
l'exécution du plan france relance
france relance je veux le dire c'est
d'abord le moteur de la reprise
économique 70 milliards d'euros auront
été engagés d'ici à la fin de l'année et
les résultats sont déjà au rendez vous
l'activité a retrouvé son niveau d'avant
crise bien avant l'objectif que nous
avions 6 et pour l'ami 2022
dans notre pays le taux d'emploi est au
plus haut depuis près de 50 ans ces
excellentes nouvelles sont évidemment
due aux plans de relance et à son
exécution rapide mais elles sont aussi
dues aux réformes structurelles que nous
avons conduite depuis 2017 et au quoi
qu'il en coûte qui a été déployé depuis
le premier jour de la crise mais france
relance c'est aussi une impulsion
écologique inédite pour notre pays six
cent cinquante mille ménages ont
notamment bénéficié de ma prime rénove
pour isoler leur logement en matière
thermique 550 mille ménages ont acquis
des véhicules électriques et hybrides
grâce aux aides qui sont consacrés grâce
à 141 projets de décarbonation
industriels nous avons réduit près de 3
millions de tonnes de co2 les émissions
mondiales dans ce secteur nous avons
soutenu près de vingt mille exploitants
agricoles dans la transition verte ce
sont autant de pas concrets que nous
prenons vers une société des carboni
france relance c'est aussi la
compétitivité retrouvée pour notre
économie la baisse de 10 milliards
d'euros des impôts de production
bénéficie à 732 1000 entreprises tandis
que 14 milliards d'euros
d'investissements productifs ont été
soutenus france relance enfin c'est le
renforcement de notre cohésion sociale
et territoriale
3 millions de jeunes ont notamment été
soutenus dans le cadre du plan un jeune
une solution tandis que 580 1000
salariés en activité partielle ont
bénéficié de formations 12500 projets
d'investissements locaux des
investissements concrets des
investissements du quotidien et de
proximité ont par ailleurs été soutenue
par les fonds du plan de relance la
deuxième communication a été présentée
par le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé et la ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique elle portait sur la situation
des apprentis dans la fonction publique
dont le nombre a presque doublé depuis
2000 16 pour approcher les 25000 ces
résultats encourageants sont dues aux
mesures que nous avons prises pour
faciliter les embauches par les trois
versants de la fonction publique y
compris des incitations financières pour
les différents employeurs
enfin la ministre de la culture a
présenté le bilan des réformes
prioritaires de son ministère notre
objectif de le dire est de démocratiser
le plus possible l'accès à la culture
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
quelle que soit leur âge quels que
soient leur territoire quelles que
soient leurs moyens financiers la
première réalisation en ce sens c'est le
pass culture de 300 euros ouvert à
l'ensemble des jeunes de 18 ans depuis
le 20 mai dernier huit cent mille
d'entre eux se sont déjà inscrits pour
en bénéficier ce qui a déjà donné lieu à
cinq millions de réservations dès 2022
le pass culture sera ouvert aux 15 16 et
17 ans et nous y serons nous estimons
donc que 4 millions de jeunes en
bénéficieront au total en 2022 l'autre
volet de notre action concerne le
développement de l'éducation artistique
et culturelle
l'objectif du gouvernement était que
100% des élèves bénéficient d'au moins
une action par an en la matière que ce
soit la découverte d'oeuvres artistiques
la rencontre d'artistes où la pratique
créative plus de six élèves sur dix ans
bénéficient déjà à ce stade malgré les
freins vous l'imaginez qui ont été
imposées par la situation sanitaire
l'institut national supérieur de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle a
par ailleurs ouvert ses portes à
guingamp en septembre 2021 voilà
mesdames messieurs ce que je pouvais
vous dire de ce conseil des ministres et
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
bonjour ma rentrée pour tf1 lci on a
compris donc que ce midi lors de ce
conte en dit vous ne donnerez pas des
annonces qui ne sont pas complètement
arbitrer quel est le sens politique de
recevoir des associations d'élus des
parlementaires est ce que c'est pour
répondre notamment aux accusations de
certains dans l'opposition qui disent
qu'aujourd'hui le président décide seul
je vous ai donné les orientations que
nous avons prises et je vous ai donné
les orientations que nous avons
aujourd'hui exclus et ce vers quoi nous
ne voulons pas revenir ensuite il ya des
mesures qui sont possibles et qui va
discuter en concertation avec les
présidents des groupes parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat cet
après midi et les représentants des
associations d'élus demain matin le sens
de cette concertation c'est tout
simplement de poursuivre notre action de
concertation on a engagé depuis le début
de cette crise ces comités de liaison
parlementaires les associations d'élus
ont été réunis à de très nombreuses
reprises à chaque fois que nous avons
eues à faire des choix en portant et à
chaque fois que nous avons été
confrontés à une reprise forte de
l'épidémie et pour ses enjeux nous avons
besoin d'une mobilisation collective je
le dis si nous voulons traverser l'hiver
et si nous voulons atteindre notre
objectif de sauver les fêtes de fin
d'année il faut une mobilisation
collective les collectivités locales
évidemment des élus des professionnels
de santé des entreprises des acteurs de
la culture de la restauration et c'est
ça vraiment que nous voulons engager
c'est pour ça aussi que les différents
ministres vont chacun concerter leurs
secteurs et isabelle borne aura des
échanges avec les partenaires sociaux
d'autres ministres avec chacun leur
secteur parce que sur l'ensemble des
sujets que j'ai évoqués sur les
orientations que j'ai donnée par exemple
sur le respect des mesures barrières le
port du masque en intérieur évidemment
que nous devons le faire en travaillant
avec les entreprises avec les
établissements recevant du public quand
on parle de l'accélération de la
campagne de rappel vaccinal évidemment
qu'il faut avancer et travailler avec
les élus locaux dont vous savez qu'ils
sont pleinement investis depuis le début
dans la campagne de vaccination pour
faire tourner des centres de vaccination
et garantir que partout sur le
territoire les français ont accès à la
vaccination est en l'occurrence c'est
l'enjeu du moment au rappel de
vaccination donc c'est à la fin un jeu
de concertation pour finaliser la bord
et les mesures que nous allons prendre
mais c'est aussi un enjeu parce
qu'encore une fois pour atteindre notre
objectif pour maintenir notre avance et
consolider nos acquis on a besoin de
continuer à avancer avec tout le monde
je permets juste d'abord des
consultations avec les élus les maires
centraux pour ouvrir dès vaccinodromes
ah bah moi j'ai dit vous avez depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il faut à être
extrêmement pragmatique et attentifs à
la situation dans chaque territoire vous
avez aujourd'hui une vaccination qui
s'est beaucoup déployé en ville c'est à
dire notamment chez les pharmaciens et
chez les médecins libéraux
vous avez des centres de vaccination qui
continuent à fonctionner vous avez
certains endroits où les centres de
vaccination on réduit leur voilure parce
qu'il y avait moins de demandes de
vaccination et puis des endroits où des
centres de vaccination parfois même
fermé évidemment il faut avoir une
approche territoire par territoire et
surtout un objectif qui est que quel que
soit le lieu où les français résident
ils doivent pouvoir accéder au rappel de
vaccination le plus facilement possible
et c'est vers ça que nous allons
continuer à avancer bonjour monsieur le
ministre fantôme seignosse canal+ on
sait que ma stratégie actuellement pour
tenter de lutter contre cette cinquième
vague épidémique repose sur deux outils
la vaccination le pass sanitaires compte
tenu de la situation épidémique actuel
qui fait que des personnes vaccinées se
contaminent à nouveau est ce que vous
allez modifier les modalités d'obtention
du passé ni terre est ce que vous
estimez que cette situation épidémique
remet en cause l'efficacité de se passer
d'abord vous avez mentionné deux outils
la vaccination et le pass sanitaire
effectivement j'en ai ajouté un
troisième j'en ai mentionné un troisième
dans mon intervention qui est évidemment
le respect des gestes barrières et la
question du port du masque qui est
évidemment centrale dit compris pour des
personnes vaccinées puisque nous le
savons la vaccination permet de réduire
de manière importante le risque de
transmettre le virus ou d'être
contaminés mais elle ne l'éteint pas
totalement et donc il ya encore cette
possibilité de pouvoir être contaminés
il ya un très faible risque de faire une
forme grave quand on est pleinement en
vacciner mais il ya encore ce risque
d'être contaminé évidemment vu des
exemples encore récemment et donc c'est
pour ça que la question des mesures
barrières du masque est aussi importante
s'agissant du pass sanitaire je renvoie
vraiment vers la conférence de presse
que donnera mon collègue olivier ferrand
demain à l'issue des concertations que
nous allons mener
moi je vous ai dit que évidemment que le
pass annie terre est un outil central
que nous voulons même le renforcer et
c'est ce qui est en train d'être décidé
et ce qui sera annoncé demain j'ai une
petite question également sur la
situation sanitaire il y a et notamment
jean castex en est l'illustration des
personnes qui se comptent année une mine
et qui ont pourtant reçu deux doses de
vaccin est ce que vous avez des données
épidémiologiques sur ces personnes qui
ont été vaccinées et qui sont à nouveaux
infectés de call back stage et il est ce
qu'il y aurait un vaccin moins efficace
que je n'ai pas d'informations
supplémentaires sur l'efficacité des
vaccins autre que celle que nous
connaissons c'est à dire que l'ensemble
des vaccins qui sont aujourd'hui validé
homologué par notre agence de santé
européennes et notre agence française
sont remarquablement efficace ensuite
nous savons ce a été établi depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois que en étant
complètement vaccinés il y a encore un
risque de pouvoir être contaminées de
transmettre le virus même s'il est
réduit il ya une étude de la drees
notamment intéressante qui a été remise
la semaine dernière qui atteste qu'il y
a je crois quatre fois moins de risque
d'être contaminé quand on est pleinement
vacciner neuf fois moins de risques
d'avoir une forme grave moi je me fie
aux études scientifiques qui sont
remises ses études elle montre que quand
on est pleinement vacciner réduit le
risque d'être contaminé de transmettre
le virus que malheureusement on ne
l'atteint pas totalement ce qui montre
qu'il faut continuer à être très
vigilants sur les gestes barrières sur
les mesures barrières le port du masque
même si encore une fois la vaccination
est un progrès absolument remarquable
est essentiel quand vous voyez
aujourd'hui la dynamique de l'épidémie
quand vous voyez le nombre de
contaminations que
constatons que nous avons encore
constaté hier si vous vous replonger un
en arrière quand nous en étions à la
deuxième vague que nous n'avions pas le
vaccin que nous n'avions pas le pass
sanitaires je pense qu'il aurait été
assez improbable de pouvoir imaginer
qu'avec une telle dynamique de
l'épidémie un tel nombre de
contaminations on aurait encore pu
continuer à se rendre au cinéma au
théâtre au restaurant ça on le doit aux
vaccins on le doit aux passes sanitaire
parce que la réalité c'est qu'ils nous
permettent aujourd'hui de protéger
l'hôpital et de ne pas constater la même
dynamique à l'hôpital que celle que nous
constatons sur les contaminations
bonjour si volontaire sur la vaccination
des enfants le boulot me demande jusqu'à
présent qu'il aurait pas de décision
avant le mois de janvier
l'agencé européenne du médicament doit
être
discutée conseils donnés sans cesse que
décision
effectivement le mois de janvier ou
plutôt le début de l'année 2022 a été
abordée parce que la décision de
l'agencé européenne du médicament devait
intervenir en toute fin d'année elle
interviendra finalement plutôt que ce
qui avait été annoncé par l'agencé
européenne du médicament et vous savez
qu ensuite c'est notre agence de santé
qui doit se prononcer dans la foulée et
à la suite de ce travail là nous
prendrons une décision je n'ai pas de
calendrier ou de date à vous annoncer
aujourd'hui mais évidemment dès lors que
l'agencé européenne du médicament aura
rendu son avis notre autorité de santé
sera saisie remettra elle aussi un avis
et nous prendrons ensuite une décision
dans la foulée favorable
jeudi nous prendrons une décision dans
la foulée
à la lumière de ce que nous aura
recommandé notre autorités sanitaires
valérie astruc france télévisions la
haute autorité de santé s'apprête à
recommander le rappel pour tous les
français de plus de 18 ans et s'apprête
aussi à recommander le raccourcissement
du délai delà du rappel de six à cinq
mois après la 2e vaccination est ce que
vous allez suivre ces pistes là
je vous parlais à l'instant des
orientations qui ont été actés ce matin
en conseil de défense et parmi ces
orientations la troisième que j'ai
évoqués c'est l'accélération de la
campagne de rappel vaccinal les pistes
que vous évoquez que vous relayez font
évidemment partie des mesures qui
peuvent nous permettre d'accélérer la
campagne de rappel vaccinal dans notre
pays et c'est ça qui va être discutée
avec les présidents des groupes
parlementaires et les associations
d'élus entre aujourd'hui et demain matin
une autre rien à voir vous confirmer
l'existence
par la france en egypte
vous savez l'egypte est un partenaire de
la france avec lequel comme beaucoup
d'autres pays nous entretenons des
relations dans le domaine du
renseignement et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est une posture assumée au
service de la sécurité régionale et de
la protection des français au cours des
dernières années l'implantation de
groupes terroristes en libye pays
voisins de l'egypte a été une source
majeure de préoccupation et nous a
conduit d'ailleurs renforcer ce
partenariat en matière de renseignement
dans le cadre de notre coopération
contre le terrorisme nous opérons des
moyens de renseignements et les règles
d'engagement de ses moyens répondent à
des exigences qui sont strictes et que
je veux rappeler elle précise et elles
définissent très précisément la mission
et soyons extrêmement claires les
problématiques domestiques sans rapport
avec la lutte contre le terrorisme
n'entre aucunement dans le champ de
cette mission de renseignement ces
règles elles sont connues de notre
partenaire est régulièrement
rappelez vous avez évoqué des
informations de presse qui ont été
relayés que faisons nous à la suite de
ces informations de presse qui ont été
relayés d'abord la ministre des armées a
lancé une enquête interne approfondie
sur les informations qui ont été révélés
par disclose c'est une enquête qui porte
sur deux volets et je veux insister sur
ce point là il ya un premier volet qui a
été je crois déjà relayées dans la
presse d'abord le fait que la détention
et la diffusion de documents classifiés
qui constitue une violation flagrante du
secret de la défense nationale et qui
met en péril la poursuite de nos
opérations de renseignement au profit de
la sécurité de nos concitoyens et donc
sur ce point la justice va être saisie
sans délai puis un deuxième volet de
cette enquête qui est important puisque
cela n'a pas été je crois à relayer l
enquête devra vérifier que les règles
qui avaient été fixés pour cette
coopération en matière de renseignement
et les mesures qui avaient été prises
pour qu'elle soit appliquée ont
effectivement été mises en oeuvre et
donc à la lumière de cette enquête on
aura évidemment l'occasion de ré
échanger sur ce sujet là si vous
m'interrogez
est ce que vous avez eu de nouvelles
mesures pour apaiser la circulation et
éviter de nouvelles violences et est ce
que le liste sébastien devra se rendre
sur
wii le président de la république a
intervenu sur ce sujet là en ouverture
du conseil des ministres il a rappelé
que notre objectif notre cap c'est de
protéger les guadeloupéens comme nous le
faisons depuis le premier jour de cette
crise je veux rappeler la mobilisation
qui a été celle de l'état et c'est
normal pour soutenir nos concitoyens aux
antilles au moment où ils ont vécu le
pire de l'épidémie sur leur territoire
avec l'envoi massif de soignants l'envoi
massif de matériel médical le recours à
l'armée aussi pour étendre encore les
capacités d'hospitalisation et que nous
devons continuer à protéger les
guadeloupéennes et guadeloupéens y
compris contre toutes formes de
délinquance que nous pouvons constater
et donc sur ce sujet là moi je veux
réitérer l'appel au calme du premier
ministre il ya une minorité
récalcitrante qui ne peut pas prendre
toute une île en otage une minorité
violente qui ne peut pas empêcher des
femmes et des hommes de se faire soigner
la santé publique ne peut pas être
instrumentalisée à des fins politiques
vous le savez nous avons envoyé des
moyens de sécurité supplémentaires cela
a été annoncé par gérald darmanin nous
avons aussi créer les conditions du
dialogue avec les annonces qui ont été
faites par le premier ministre lundi
soir l'établissement d'un dialogue
social avec les personnels hospitaliers
qui ne sont pas vaccinés je rappelle que
87% des soignants de lille le sont et
puis le déploiement d'une mission de la
direction générale de la sécurité civile
pour établir le dialogue avec les
pompiers du sdiss et le département de
la guadeloupe qui rappelons le est
l'autorité gestionnaire du
10 et donc nous allons poursuivre cette
mobilisation et s'agissant du la visite
de sébastien lecornu sur place je crois
qu'il est lui-même intervenu hier matin
et qu'il a indiqué qu'il se rendrait sur
place d'ailleurs dès lors que les
conditions seraient réunies c'est ce
qu'il a dit je crois hier matin sur
france 2
bonjour elizabeth pineau de l' agence
reuters est ce que stéphane richard doit
quitter la tête du groupe orange après
sa condamnation dans l'affairé tapie sur
ce point là je crois que mes collègues
de bercy sont intervenus nous prenons
acte de la décision qui a été rendue il
ya je crois un conseil d'administration
qui se tient aujourd'hui et c'est à ce
moment là que les conséquences de vont
être retirés j'ai pas d'autres éléments
à vous donner que ceux qui ont été
communiqués par bercy à quelques minutes
j'ai une question politique renaud
muselier vient de quitter les
républicains va-t-il rejoindre le camp
présidentiel
vous savez je
vous savez je je je m'efforce je crois
que j'ai tenus cet objectif depuis que
je suis parent parole du gouvernement de
ne pas parler de politique partisane sur
ce pupitre je suis régulièrement invité
dans des émissions de télé de radio je
fais des interviews on peut me poser ces
questions là et je réponds mais je
considère que ici à l'elysée derrière
son pupitre en sortie du conseil des
ministres je ne suis pas là pour parler
de politique partisane et par ailleurs
vous comprendrez que à la lumière de la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons des enjeux extrêmement lourd
sur lesquels nous travaillons en ce
moment ça ne me paraît pas être une
priorité absolue que de commenter ce
sujet
bonjour je viens l'écuyer la voix du
nord je voulais écrire c'est un petit
peu puisque vous avez parlé d'un cap
clair côté celui de ne pas revenir sur
les jours
l'idée mesures de confinement tant que
faire se peut
est ce que ça vous a signifié qu'il
fallait exclure que vous excluiez déjà
des mesures de 2000 jauge dans les
établissements scolaires c'est à dire de
venir au niveau 3 du protocole dans
l'éducation nationale moi vous le savez
je fais toujours la même réponse sur ce
sujet là je n'exclus jamais rien par
principe pour l'avenir voilà c'est la
lumière de ces ce que j'ai appris de 18
mois un peu moins de peur par là
je ne peux rien exclure pour l'avenir
c'est aussi un des enseignements de
cette épidémie ce que je vous dis en
revanche c'est qu'elles sont nos
objectifs et je redis les autres vous
avez répété c'est pas la peine que je le
répète les objectifs que j'ai rappelé à
l'instant s'agissant de notre gestion de
l'épidémie dans la droite ligne de ce
que nous faisons depuis l'arrivée de la
vaccination est depuis l'allocution du
président de la république le 12 juillet
avec le pass sanitaires c'est encore une
fois de nous appuyer sur la vaccination
et le rappel vaccinal sur le pass
sanitaires sur les gestes barrières
précisément pour ne pas avoir à en
revenir à des mesures qui impacte la vie
collective voilà maintenant je peux pas
vous jeu j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire
que dans x men ou dans x mois j'exclus
que nous prenions telle décision
malheureusement ce serait je le dis ça
ne serait pas sérieux de ma part que de
vous répondre mais ça ne doit pas non
plus conduire parce que ça aussi je les
observe en tant que porte parole
maintenant quand je n'exclus pas quelque
chose à considérer que ça devient
quelque chose qui est sérieusement
envisagée voilà je la nuance est pas
forcément simple pour tout le monde mais
je pense qu'il faut essayer d'être le
plus précis et le plus fidèle à ce que
nous disons est ce que nous envisageons
deuxième question s'il vous plaît
on a constaté quand même chez les
français une certaine fatigue évidemment
concernant toutes les mesures sanitaires
fatigue et parfois colère vis-à-vis des
certaines devises et les vidéos qui
émergent et qui montre quelques écarts
des deux membres du gouvernement
est ce que la lumière de ces éléments
est ce que le gouvernement est inquiet
de l'acceptabilité par les français de
nouvelles mesures qui seraient qui
seraient prises de demain d'abord
évidemment qu'il ya une lassitude très
force défend très fort des français
vis-à-vis de cette épidémie je me
déplace régulièrement partout sur le
territoire national je le constate en
échangeant avec les français évidemment
qu'il ya une lassitude qu'on en a tous
marre qu'on a on peut parfois avoir le
sentiment qu'on n'en verra jamais le
bout ça s'est très largement partagé par
l'ensemble des français je connais pas
de français qui sont satisfaits entre
guillemets de devoir vivre avec ce virus
et je dis ça vaut pour tous les français
ça vaut pour tout le monde dans le monde
puisque le monde continuent à être
confrontés à cette épidémie on a des
progrès qui ont été enregistrés encore
une fois grâce à la vaccination on
constate que l'on traverse chaque vague
je le crois profondément un peu mieux
que la précédente précisément parce
qu'on renforce nos outils et parce que
grâce à la vaccination on peut
aujourd'hui éviter d'en revenir à des
mesures qui ont très fortement et très
gravement impacté la vie collective des
français mais oui il ya cette lassitude
que j'entends parfaitement s'agissant
ensuite du gouvernement nous avons
évidemment être scrupuleux nous avons
évidemment comme tous les français un
devoir une responsabilité de vigilance
je crois que nous avons en plus de cela
évidemment un devoir d'exemplarité
vous évoquez des images ou des scènes
qui sont relayées sur les réseaux
sociaux moi ce que je veux rappeler
simplement c'est que pour l'ensemble des
événements des rendez-vous qui sont
organisées par les ministres dans les
différents ministères il ya une demande
qui est très claire du président la
république et du premier ministre c'est
de respecter scrupuleusement les règles
et les protocoles sanitaires aujourd'hui
les règles et les protocoles sanitaires
qui s'applique prévoit je vous dis
aujourd'hui même à l'heure à laquelle je
vous parle prévoit que dans les lieux où
les rassemblements soumis aux passes
sanitaire vous pouvez retirer le masque
c'est aujourd'hui les règles telles
qu'elles existent et c'est les
protocoles qui sont appliquées
maintenant évidemment que lorsqu'il y
aura des évolutions
ces règles elles seront évidemment
appliquer aussi parlé par les ministères
si vous avez des questions plus précises
sur des réunions qui ont eu lieu sur le
respect des protocoles dans le cadre de
ses réunions je vous invite vraiment
aller poser aux différents ministères
qui ont pu organiser des réunions et qui
vous donnerons tous les éléments mais
encore une fois je rappelle l'exigence
très claire du président et du premier
ministre c'est le respect des protocoles
sanitaires évidemment dans tous les
événements auxquels participent les
membres du gouvernement
bonjour nocilla ministre agathe un vrai
pour des intérêts une question sur
nicolas hulot à nouveau accusé de viol
il annoncera est un chéneau qu'ils
quittent la vie publique il y avait déjà
été mise en cause quand il était
ministre de ce gouvernement à l'effet
que fin précédent gouvernement l'époque
il avait reçu le soutien d'edouard
philippe aujourd'hui est ce que vous
comprenez sa décision j'ai pas de
commentaires à faire c'est une décision
personnelle qui a été prise par nicolas
hulot qui n'est plus membre du
gouvernement et donc ça n'appelle pas de
commentaire de ma part
sur ce sujet
je me fais le porte parole de paul
larrouturou pour l'instant paul sur lci
sur la question sanitaire des meetings
politiques à venir est ce que le pass
sanitaire ne pourrait-il pas être
obligatoire dans ces grands
rassemblements alors que gérald darmanin
a écrit dans une dans une circulaire
qu'il ne serait pas nécessaire on pense
au grand meeting au zénith d'eric
zemmour le 5 décembre prochain le grand
rassemblement des républicains le 11
décembre est ce que tous ces grands
meetings ne risque pas de devenir des
clusters géant si le pass n'est pas
demandée alors beaucoup sur ce sujet là
il me semble qu'il y à une décision du
conseil constitutionnel qui date je
crois du 31 mai qui indique que nous ne
pouvons pas conditionner l'accès à un
meeting politique au pass sanitaires de
manière obligatoire nous respectons
évidemment toutes les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel qui sont rendus
c'est le gardien de notre constitution
des principes fondamentaux de la
république maintenant rien n'empêche un
organisateur d'une réunion politique
d'exiger le pass sanitaires pour y
accéder voilà la réponse que je peux
vous faire
un dernier point monsieur monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure vous avez
expliqué que le gouvernement souhaitait
un site et faire peser les contraintes
sur celles et ceux qui je vous cite ne
prennent pas leurs responsabilités ce
que vous ciblez les personnes qui ne
sont toujours pas vaccinées aujourd'hui
dans notre pays est ce que vous pouvez
éclaircir ces propos est-ce que des
mesures pourraient concerner uniquement
les non vaccinés dans les prochaines
semaines oui je faisais référence aux
personnes je crois qu'elles sont près de
6 millions qui n'ont pas encore je
l'espère fait le choix de la vaccination
et jeudi par encore parce que nous avons
constaté à la suite de la dernière
allocution du président de la république
qu'il y avait une augmentation des
premières doses et prise de rendez vous
pour des premières doses c'est à dire
des français depuis près d'un an que la
vaccination se déploie dans notre pays
un peu moins en réalité pour les - âgées
font le choix aujourd'hui je pense parce
qu'il voit aussi que la situation
sanitaire se dégradent d'aller se faire
vacciner évidemment qu'il faut le saluer
moi je peux entendre qu'il est français
qui est puis appliquez pu avoir des
doutes ou des inquiétudes je dis qu'on a
maintenant à un recul suffisamment
important un nombre de vaccinations
suffisamment importantes qui ont eu lieu
pour confirmer à la fois que le vaccin
est redoutablement efficace et ensuite
qu'il n'y a pas de risque à faire cette
vaccination donc je peux des français
aujourd'hui fassent le choix d'aller se
faire vacciner un choix qu'il n'avait
pas fait avant évidemment que le salut
je crois que dans les jours qui ont
suivi l'allocution du président la
république c'est une augmentation de 20%
des premières injections on partait de
bah évidemment puisque il y en avait
beaucoup moins mais c'est quand même à
saluer et à souligner ensuite je vous ai
dit que dans les trois orientations que
nous avons acté celle du renforcement du
pass sanitaire avec comme logique
effectivement d'avoir un pass sanitaire
qui est plus sécurisant ça veut dire
qu'on va continuer à augmenter des
contrôles vous savez gérald darmanin est
intervenu sur ce sujet là qu'on a
augmenté nos contrôles qui permettent
d'être d'attester que le pass sanitaires
et bien requis est demandé dans les
lieux où il est aujourd'hui nécessaire
on va continuer à augmenter ses
contrôles c'est aussi l'enjeu des
concertations qui auront lieu cet
après-midi par les différents ministres
avec les différents secteurs on a besoin
d'eux pour que le pass sanitaire puisse
être utilisé partout où il est
aujourd'hui nécessaire moi je le dis
vraiment aux responsables des
restaurants des bars de tous les lieux
où le pastel iter est aujourd'hui
nécessaire
utiliser le pass and i ter demandé le
passé ni terre à vos clients parce que
c'est en faisant respecter nos règles
c'est en étant extrêmement scrupuleux
que nous parviendrons à tenir et à
sauver les fêtes de fin d'année est donc
évidemment dans le renforcement des
règles du pass sanitaire qui est
envisagé il ya évidemment ce souhait de
continuer à aller plus loin et de ne pas
faire peser la contrainte sur les
français qui se sont fait vacciner qui
ont leurs passes sanitaire mais plutôt
sur ce qui nous fait le choix de ne pas
se faire vacciner
dans notre pays
bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je vous remercie
je vous dis à la semaine prochaine